[Aplausos]
[Música]
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero por qué debería importarme lo que
ocurre en Georgia el país no el estado
de Estados Unidos
Pues bien podríamos decir que Georgia es
la precuela de Ucrania antes de que
Putin invadería quirmea los georgianos
ya habían recibido la visita de los
tanques rusos de hecho todavía hoy en
día Rusia controla de facto dos regiones
de este país abjasia josetia del sur y
antes mucho antes de que se convirtiera
en el enemigo número uno de Vladimir
Putin mijael sacas Billy era quien
ocupaba este puesto y creedme hablamos
de odio de verdad atentos a las palabras
de Putin Vladimir Putin amenazado con
colgar de las pelotas al líder de
Georgia si sois veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik ya sabéis de quién nos
estamos hablando y si no lo sois os
presento a uno de los personajes más
fascinantes y controvertidos de la
política internacional siempre he
pensado que si hubiera sido americano
sacassville tendría ya por lo menos
cuatro series en Netflix y dos en hbo
porque sí este hombre fue presidente de
Georgia Bajo su mandato la economía
despegó y esta república exoviética se
acercó a occidente más que nunca pero
las personas de las elecciones renunció
a su nacionalidad georgiana y se hizo
ucraniano y en Ucrania llegó a ser
gobernador de Odessa Incluso zelensky le
llegó a nombrar director del Consejo
Nacional de reformas sin embargo en 2021
decidió volver a su Georgia natal pero
no creáis que lo hizo en avión como una
persona normal no cruza la frontera
escondido en el tráiler de un camión de
productos lácteos Y diréis por qué Pues
porque en Georgia tenía una orden de
detención es decir que en cualquier
control fronterizo se lo podrían llevar
preso
habéis oído bien sacas Billy no deja
indiferente a nadie y muchos geanos
todavía lo apoyan pero otros le odian y
entre los que le odian están los que
controlan el país estoy encarcelado por
un régimen que está usando mi cautividad
para contentar a Vladimir Putin mijais
El caso es que nada más llegar fue
detenido y mandado ipso facto a prisión
tanto por entrar ilegalmente en el país
como por otros seis delitos que tenía
pendientes desde entonces su estado de
salud empeorado drásticamente parte es
por las huelgas de hambre que ha
protagonizado pero también hay indicios
de cosas mucho más preocupantes atentos
y nuevas grabaciones el expresidente
georgiano y enemigo de Putin denuncia
malos tratos en medio de acusaciones de
que está siendo envenenado pero lo más
importante de esta historia es que es el
síntoma de algo mucho más grande Georgia
está tendiendo puentes con el kremlin y
la pregunta es por qué pensadlo así
hablamos de un país que de facto tiene
territorios invadidos por Rusia un país
que ha recibido a miles de rusos que
precisamente estaban escapando del
régimen de Putin como es posible que
tengan tan buena con Moscú son ciertas
las conexiones entre Moscú y el partido
sueño georgiano que es el que está en el
poder Qué implicaciones puede tener la
Guerra de Ucrania en todo esto hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de Historia
[Música]
La odisea georgiana
seguro que muchos de vosotros ya sabréis
que Georgia fue parte de la unión
soviética lo que seguro que no sabréis
tanto es que también Fue la cuna de uno
de los líderes soviéticos más
importantes de la historia alguna idea
adivináis de quién estamos hablando Pues
sí Ni más ni menos que de yoshif stalin
pero no nos adelantemos porque antes de
que Georgia fuera parte de la unión
soviética lo fue de otros imperios desde
la antigua Grecia y el Imperio Romano
hasta los persas y los otomanos el
territorio de Georgia estuvo casi bajo
control de alguna potencia extranjera
durante buena parte de su historia esos
territorios estuvieron unificados y
fueron relativamente prósperos entre el
siglo X y el siglo xii pero a partir de
ahí y prácticamente hasta el siglo XIX
todo fueron invasiones y saqueos la
situación era tan mala que los
principados en los que se dividía el
actual Georgia pidieron Incluso
integrarse en Rusia para al menos
conseguir protección y por supuesto la
consiguieron ahora bien A qué precio
Pues a uno bastante elevado porque las
campañas de resucificación comenzaron
casi de inmediato eso alimentó el
nacionalismo local lo que condujo junto
al golpe de estado bolchevique en Rusia
de 1917 a declarar la independencia
georgiana en ese mismo año Claro que
esto no duró mucho tiempo porque apenas
cuatro años más tarde en 1921 la unión
soviética volvió a anexar este
territorio
[Música]
entonces la nueva Georgia soviética
comenzó a experimentar un cierto proceso
de industrialización y Urbanización pero
también sufrió duramente la represión
típica del estado soviético y las
campañas de homogenización cultural y
étnica o un proceso que se extendió
hasta 1991 cuando el colapso de la unión
soviética volvió a dar paso a la
independencia de Georgia sin embargo
otra Odisea estaba a punto de comenzar
nada más conseguir la independencia
empezaron a surgir todo tipo de
problemas una guerra civil conflictos
étnicos en la afgasia y ositia del sur
Una durísima crisis económica etcétera
etcétera con semejante percal el
oligarca soviético Edward severnache el
último ministro de exteriores de la
mismísimo unión soviética fue puesto por
los militares al frente del país tras un
golpe de estado en 1992 al principio sus
datos no fueron del todo malos logró
terminar con la guerra civil en 1995 y
la economía comenzó a mejorar
ligeramente después de que el pib cayera
un 78% entre el 91 y el 95
sin embargo los problemas se fueron
acumulando un 50% de la población no
llegaba a fin de mes la corrupción
seguía acampando a sus anchas por todas
las esquinas y el autoritarismo se había
convertido en la característica
fundamental del gobierno al final
después de amenazar y coaccionar a la
cadena de televisión rustabit 2 y de ser
acusado de amañar las elecciones llegó
el acontecimiento que transformaría
Georgia la revolución de Las Rosas y
quién lideraba esa Revolución Exacto
nuestro amigo sacasbili
[Música]
era abogado de profesión y ex ministro
de Justicia del propio se bernatze se
reveló contra el que fue su padrino
político y acabó exigiendo su dimisión
en su propio despacho al final entre la
presión ejercida por sus propios
círculos y por las protestas en las
calles severnaches se vio obligado a
tirar la toalla y abandonar el poder en
2004 sacas Billy ganó las elecciones
presidenciales por una mayoría
abrumadora Y a partir de ahí pues bueno
digamos que el país de un vuelco de 180
grados las medidas anticorrupción
hicieron que Georgia avanzara en muy
pocos años del puesto 133 al 51 en 2012
esto en transparencia al mismo tiempo la
reformas económicas le lanzaron el país
podríamos decir que Georgia tenía un
objetivo muy claro convertirse en una
especie de Edén liberal en materia
económica para ello el gobierno de
sacasmín le hizo todo lo que os podéis
esperar e incluso más introdujo una
regulación laboral muy flexible bajo los
aranceles bajo los impuestos redujo la
burocracia y abrió el exterior
particularmente a occidente la economía
de Georgia sin embargo mis queridos
amigos de visualpoliti todo lo que
reluce los gobiernos de sacasbili tenían
otra cara pronto surgieron denuncias
sobre ataques a la libertad de prensa
represión a partidos de la oposición y
nuevos casos de corrupción y como os
podéis imaginar todo esto hizo que el
propio sacas el año 2007 para volver a
ganar las elecciones apenas Un año más
tarde en 2008 sin embargo durante su
segundo mandato aunque las reformas
económicas continuaron las acusaciones
volvieron a repetirse y lo que es aún
peor en 2008 sufrió el ataque militar de
Rusia
en 2008 tras una serie de
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas
independentistas de los setia del sur y
campesinos que se identificaban como
georgianos en una decisión quizás
incomprensible sajas Billy movilizó el
ejército para poner fin de una vez por
todas a la violencia de los separatistas
apoyados por Rusia y vaya la que se lió
El Criminal vio la oportunidad acusó al
gobierno georgiano de querer llevar a
cabo una limpieza étnica lo que
supuestamente justificaba su
intervención ya sabéis es algo de lo que
ellos hemos hablado en este canal la
doctrina cara ganó que básicamente
consiste en que Rusia tiene que ser el
protector de los ciudadanos rusa en los
países de su órbita Esta es sin ir más
lejos la excusa que también ha utilizado
Rusia para invadir Ucrania en dos
ocasiones primero en 2014 cuando se
anexionó crimea y luego otra vez en 2022
Y por supuesto también fue la excusada
que puso para atacar e invadir Georgia
en 2008 las tropas rusas llegaron a
territorio georgiano y avanzaron hasta
llegar a 40 kilómetros de su capital al
tiempo que la fuerza aérea dañó
objetivos estratégicos finalmente apenas
un par de semanas después del comienzo
del conflicto llegaron a un alto el
fuego Y entonces Rusia reconoció
oficialmente la independencia de euhasia
y osetia del Sur
conclusión Pues que sacas Billy fracasó
en su promesa de restaurar la integridad
territorial de Georgia y para colmo sus
medidas no estaban resolviendo Con
urgencia otro de los grandes problemas
del país los bajos sueldos y Las bajas
pensiones Así que en las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2013 sacas villy
decidió presentarse y su partido recibió
un duro castigo un nuevo actor político
se llevó todo el protagonismo de quién
estamos hablando Exacto del partido
sueño georgiano atentos
[Música]
el sueño lúcido del multimillonario
soviético
nacido en el año 2012 el sueño georgiano
ha dominado la política georgiana desde
Entonces hasta nuestros días con una
posición un poco más escorada al centro
izquierda ha sido acusado en reiterados
ocasiones de blanquear en el país a la
Rusia de Putin este partido no podría
haber llegado hasta donde está sin el
impulso de su fundador el
multimillonario virgina y vanish Billy
Así que si queremos echar un vistazo a
las acusaciones que se le hacen sobre
sus nexos con Rusia lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es conocer un poco
mejor a este buen señor a ivanissville
hablamos del hombre más rico de Georgia
un tipo que hizo su fortuna en Rusia con
negocios muchas veces un poco
cuestionables y que regresó a su país
natal tras el éxito de la revolución de
Las Rosas Incluso en su día apoyó al
propio sacasbili un apoyo que duró hasta
2011 cuando empezó a poner en marcha su
propio proyecto político hablamos por
supuesto del partido sueño georgiano
partido que ganó por mayoría las
elecciones parlamentarias de 2012 aunque
le valió convertirse en el Primer
Ministro Y aunque de repente apenas un
año después decidió dejar su cargo Lo
cierto es que se mantuvo como presidente
dueño y Señor de su partido pocas dudas
en Georgia hay de quemanis Billy es
quien maneja todos los hilos sea como
sea la cuestión es que el sueño es
prusianos ha cobrado especial
importancia en los últimos tiempos y
diréis por qué Pues porque su posición
frente a Rusia es totalmente diferente a
la que hubiera tenido nuestro buen amigo
sacasbili el partido del multimillonario
georgiano ha adoptado un discurso mucho
menos agresivo con Rusia incluso tras su
criminal invasión de Ucrania y diréis
por qué pues Quizás por el temor a que
la economía del país estanque todavía
más si se enfrenta a Rusia porque sí mis
queridos amigos y amigas de
visualpolitik si hablamos de economía
tenemos que reconocer que los últimos
años no han sido particularmente buenos
para Georgia y al final pues qué quieres
que os diga Rusia es un importante socio
comercial para este país fijaos
como veis Rusia es el segundo mayor
mercado para las exportaciones de
Georgia y también es su segundo
proveedor más importante quizás todo
esto explica Por qué este gobierno ha
recibido tantas acusaciones de blanquear
las acciones de Rusia y de menospreciar
sus relaciones con la Unión Europea y
desde luego noticias como esta no ayudan
precisamente a su imagen el sueño
Georgia no anula el acuerdo de 19 de
abril del Consejo de la Unión Europea
Claro que no hablamos de acusaciones
estrictamente nuevas en el año 2019 ya
se produjo un gran revuelo cuando sueño
georgiano invitó un parlamentario
comunista ruso sergey garry Love al
parlamento Y si esto ya levantaba
sospechas cuando Gabriel Love se sentó
en la silla del presidente del
parlamento y empezó a dar un discurso en
ruso sobre la unión de Rusia y Georgia
Entonces los georgianos estallaron las
protestas exigiendo dimisiones brotaron
en las calles y ya de paso la oposición
comenzó a pedir una reforma electoral
para que los resultados de las
elecciones fueran totalmente
proporcionales Y qué creéis que pasó
Pues esta vez contra todo pronóstico
consiguieron la dimisión del presidente
del parlamento y también
reforma electoral lo más sorprendente de
todo es que pese a todas las
manifestaciones y escándalos este
partido sigue ganando las lecciones y
para colmo justo cuando su imagen estaba
más deteriorada estalló la pandemia del
coronavirus y aquí hay que decir que una
amplia mayoría de la población considera
que la gestión que se hizo de la
pandemia fue buena o muy buena increíble
pero cierto Georgia es uno de esos pocos
países donde la covid-19 lejos de
castigar al gobierno le supuse todo un
chute de popularidad y de esta forma en
2021 volvieron a ganar las elecciones
locales Eso sí con muchas acusaciones de
fraude intimidación en los centros de
votación sea como sea la Guerra de
Ucrania lo ha cambiado todo y cómo este
partido geciano frente a este nuevo reto
es algo que puede ser determinante para
supervivencia y una clave para el futuro
de este país atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
La pesadilla georgiana o el milagro ruso
creo que ninguno se va a sorprender si
digo que el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania a salpicado a Georgia y no
precisamente porque se hayan visto
envueltos en este mismo sino porque este
país ha recibido cientos de miles de
exiliados que huyen de las consecuencias
de la guerra pero ojo porque no hablamos
de exiliados ucranianos atentos
muchos que huyen de la guerra de Putin
añaden un nuevo foco de conflicto a las
viejas tensiones en la cercana a Georgia
los rusos que huyen a Georgia del
reclutamiento para la Guerra de Ucrania
están agravando las tensiones existentes
desde hace generaciones entre ambos
países Exacto hablamos de los exiliados
rusos que se han marchado porque o bien
se oponen a la guerra o bien no quieren
correr el riesgo de ser reclutados para
luchar en el frente y sí
mayoritariamente son esas personas las
que están llegando a Georgia de hecho
desde el comienzo de la guerra hasta el
anuncio de reclutamiento masivo de Putin
en septiembre cerca de 40.000 rusos se
trasladaron a Georgia pero sabéis que
justo después de que se anunciara la
movilización parcial cientos de miles de
rusos llegaron de repente este pequeño
país de todos ellos estima que unos
100.000 se han quedado a residir en
Georgia es decir casi un 3% de toda la
población georgiana en apenas unas pocas
semanas Georgia todavía no llega a los
niveles de países como Estonia donde los
refugiados ucranianos ya suponen
alrededor del 5% de la población
pre-guerra pero aun así Hablamos de una
cifra muy relevante ahora la cuestión es
que esta llegada masiva de población
rusa está teniendo para un efecto tanto
positivo como negativo fijaos en esta
tabla
una buena parte de todos los
profesionales que han oído de Rusia
tienen perfiles altamente cualificados
especialmente lo que respecta al sector
tecnológico y ahora Georgia se está
beneficiando de ello de hecho hasta en
Los pequeños pueblos más pobres y
recónditos del país se ha experimentado
un cierto Boom económico aunque solo sea
porque les venden a los rusos
direcciones postales para que puedan
establecer en ella sus negocios en total
se calcula que los rusos que han llegado
a Georgia han emprendido ya unos 10.000
negocios en el país y de hecho a lo
largo de 2022 la entrada de capital es a
Georgia tuvo efectos significativos por
ejemplo la reserva de Divisas
internacionales incrementaron un 12,2%
hasta los 4.900 millones de dólares y el
Ari y la moneda local se apareció un 13%
pero esperad un momento porque no todo
es un campo de rosas los georgianos no
se han olvidado aún de lo que Rusia les
hizo en el año 2008 y el hecho de que el
20% del territorio nacional Sigue
estando bajo dominio ruso desde luego no
ayuda Así que muchos de los rusos que
han llegado ahora sufren numerosos casos
de discriminación Y por supuesto
terminan pagando justos por pecadores
incluso los rusos que están en contra de
Putin están sufriendo una situación que
amenaza la paz social
Claro que ese no es el único problema
porque la llegada de rusos también está
alimentando una enorme escasez de
viviendas como os podéis imaginar los
rusos necesitan encontrar un lugar para
vivir lo que es pura gasolina para la
demanda inmobiliaria Pero eso no es todo
porque pensad que hablamos en muchos
casos de profesionales con ingresos
relativamente altos así que están
dispuestos a pagar mucho más por esas
viviendas lo que multiplica el problema
para que os hagáis una idea desde que
diera el comienzo la Guerra de Ucrania
los precios de los alquileres en tiflis
se han disparado algunas estimaciones
hablan de incrementos del alquiler de
Hasta el 210% y por otra parte el precio
de las viviendas en propiedad se
incrementó un 28% En comparación con el
año 2021 en cualquier caso a pesar de
las tensiones en el mercado inmobiliario
en términos generales creo que podemos
decir que Georgia está saliendo
beneficiada de la llegada de los
exiliados rusos y sabéis que esto nos
lleva directamente a una cuestión clave
ahora que Rusia está sufriendo enormes
pérdidas militares en Ucrania y su
fuerza está debilitada mientras que
Georgia está Aparentemente
fortaleciéndose se atreverá a tiflis
reclamar los territorios invadidos en
2008 por ciento defraudados Pero lo más
seguro es que no y diréis por qué Pues
porque entre otras cosas cuando Rusia
invadía Ucrania a principios del 2022 el
gobierno del sueño jorgegiano condenó el
acto pero no se sumó a las sanciones
internacionales contra el régimen de
Putin
[Música]
por supuesto no debemos olvidar el
tamaño del ejército ruso claro muchos
estarás diciendo que tampoco es para
tanto Mira cómo les va los ucranianos
pero no confundáis el tamaño del
ejército ucraniano que es uno de los 15
más grandes del mundo mientras que la
georgiano es mucho más Modesto entre
otras cosas porque este país tiene
apenas 3,7 millones de habitantes y
tampoco olvidemos que George hacia
frontera con la chechenia de kadir off
es decir El Punto de partida de Georgia
es mucho peor que el de otras pequeñas
repúblicas ex soviéticas como Estonia
letonia lituania que sí pueden actuar
con mucha más libertad e Independencia
por lo tanto lo más probable es que el
gobierno de este partido del partido
sueño georgiano no quiera complicarse
demasiado la vida sobre todo después de
la pandemia y busca recoger los frutos
del exilio ruso y llegado al caso quién
sabe quizás incluso convertirse en algo
así como un puente para que Rusia se
salte alguna de las sanciones
occidentales lo que por supuesto podría
acabar definitivamente con el viejo
sueño georgiano de integrarse en
occidente pero dicho esto la pregunta
ahora es para vosotros creéis que
Georgia debería alinearse con Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea y las
sanciones contra Rusia logrará sacar
rendimiento económico de la guerra
seguirán pasando por alto los georgianos
la delicada situación de sacas Billy
podéis dejarnos vuestras opiniones aquí
abajo en los comentarios y como siempre
no olvidéis Que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]